hi today I'd like to start telling you
about a series of very short films I've
got to be doing
and these films have come about by me
now taking on people around the globe
who wish to do bookie was a
certification for teachers levels
the teachers levels are being described
in the
wildmaru.com website so if you need to
know more please look there
okay so things I'd like to talk about is
first of all the etiquette
you should always be nicely dressed
clean gig and a lot of you may take this
for granted but over the past few years
the modern generation I'm sure we're
doing a lot natural likely say this but
they've lapsed in uh no really about the
etiquette that we should have in martial
arts claiming that their nurses are very
important factor your key should be have
a nice quality affects you well the
slave should be correct something that
somebody can grab you not hanging down
here where you have to keep pulling them
up you shouldn't roll them up at this
disrespectful
I mean it's insane as well in the month
but uh I'm just telling you how how it
how it should be about
um trying to get the the ends of the
same size let's do another job and and a
lot of people will disagree but at the
rear you want them to be nice and smooth
like this not crossed over
a lot of people about on with equal
piece hanging out the sides they put it
on and wrap it down and they turn it
over they bring it around and at the
back it's got cross over like this
it's okay for a lot of martial arts but
for Ike you know because you roll a lot
I've explained in another film that it
can roll into sort of a solar a knot
that's about formula
okay the trousers should be
at this correct level the available
higher if you wish but they shouldn't be
hanging on the ground
because traditionally we do weapons
outside we don't wear a hakama while
doing the weapons
if you have the hakima it should be
about the same level for these trousers
you can turn the trousers up that that's
acceptable if you've got the hacker one
because obviously it's not going to be
saved but it's better to have the
trousers
so it doesn't show below the hakama in
normal times
a lot of casualness is becoming the
martial arts not just Aikido and and
I know I sound perhaps an old dinosaur
old fossil whatever you want to call it
but
you're either going to do the art and
find all the benefits or you're going to
play around with it and have a capital
attitude of uh I'll do what I like
so I'm not trying to tell anyone off I'm
just saying that correctness means
sharpness sharpness of attitude means a
good quality martial artist
okay so this is the I want to just go
back to why I'm going to make this
series of films
I should take each segment and I will
explain
what I've seen wrong so I've taken about
20 people from around the globe
for their first and second and bookie
whatever teaching certification
and when you play with them on slow
motion because they either send me in
the films and the link and I
go find my flame and check the points
because they have to be exact because
their teacher certification not just
training as a student barricade you know
what you do to students okay what you do
as a teacher is very important
so to me the importance is to be correct
so out of these around about 20 might be
just over now applicants have
asked that would be certified I know
it's a pattern and this pattern is
over a large proportion it's I would say
are all doing the same week weaknesses
within the book he was like Canon
General but we'll start with the cane
and we'll we'll slowly go to the Joe and
I'll just explain what the weakness is
how to correct it and why you should
correct it
um I'd like to say that many people have
sent in photo Clips saying ah but psycho
Sensei didn't do this that way the way
you want it done
so I then have to research because what
I had done I followed such a Sensei for
27 years over that span 19 years I
followed him for twice a year
for 19 years every year twice a year I
went to one
well I was into Walmart for three weeks
I obtained my fourth damn book you was a
certification
I in the same weight I obtain my feet
then taijitsu
on the last week I obtained my fifth and
the final level googly wiser and that
means that he gives you this
certification that I can vet other
people and award these certification
certificates
um with my scrutiny you can't go any
higher than five levels and there's
around 10 people in the world who have
this certification I don't know only one
other who does look at the weapons
people just for weapons and award
certificates
but minor teacher certifications not
like passing a day in raid where you
pass as a student I want to see the
quality preciseness the pace in which
it's taught so that I can pass on what
cytosancy was passed on by homosexy and
that is so excited says he became older
he slowed it down refined everything and
and this is what I'm trying do as well
I'm trying to pick out where he left off
and do it slowly methodically precisely
here like the art with one word what I
gave him in 19 in August September I
think it was 1984.
if I would keep his weapons
um
in Europe he said North America is fine
there really there's a lot of people out
there who know my weapons I've given the
certification and I'm happy with them
but in Europe they used to have any
keep mine at no sense as I could go live
he added to this and he said but please
develop Ken and JoJo
so sometimes when you see my suggestion
you may think oh but it doesn't like
seeing what he said on a film but
perhaps since he when he said that was
at the age of 50 he may not have been
saying it when I was with him at the age
of 70.
so there's always going to be yes but
what if and that but I'm giving you the
best knowledge I can so I saw him for 27
years he changed tremendous care with
that period and rather than
training like some really superb fast
aikidoka you become a master who
methodically wanted us his top students
to also give it to the world but in a
correct manner
thank you for listening I hope you enjoy
the set of films I should be making that
be short and I'll be based on each part
thank you